[Музика]
дозвольте мені бути абсолютно ясним,
Сполучені Штати ніколи не
визнають спробу Росії анексувати
Крим
[Оплески]
[Музика]
Це те, що говорити, що це просто
, немає виправдання,
тоді як Росія продовжує надсилати своїх
головорізів
свої війська  найманці через
кордон
російські танки та ракети все ще
заповнюють донбас
сепаратистські сили організовані під
командуванням і
керівництвом москви за москвою,
тому Сполучені Штати продовжуватимуть
стояти з україною проти російської
агресії,
ми надаємо підтримку, щоб допомогти,
навчати та допомагати вашим силам безпеки
і ми покладалися на те, щоб
об’єднати решту світу для справи України,
коли я востаннє був із Путіним, і ми були
в його кабінеті наодинці,
я дивлюся в твої очі, а у тебе
немає душі
[Музика]
[Оплески]
написав вірш після того, як хвалиться тим, що заявляє
про дух України, закликаючи своїх співвітчизників
повстати і вимагати
свободи
його вірш Заповіт закінчується
цим  флексія
і я цитую тоді в могутній родині
всіх вільних людей,
можливо, іноді
ви говорите про мене
дуже тихо, можливо, іноді дуже тихо ви
говорите про мене,
леді та панове
[Оплески]
я буду говорити про Україну, весь
світ дивиться на вас
це ти факт